congratulations officially because
season two was picked up
and yes knew this was going to happen i
feel like
months ago are you on that set right now
is it yours no i'm currently today is
one of my days off
which is nice but yeah everybody's
shooting today
i am not on my days off usually i'll go
and get kobe tested so i'll visit set
i'll say hi to everybody um so i'm gonna
do that after
this what is it like to resume shooting
i mean amid a pin a pandemic what kind
of
protocols are in place it's um
it's complete it's definitely different
um
for sure it feels obvious with all the
protocols
that are in place they're keeping
everyone safe and
it's great like we're very we're lucky
and very fortunate to be back shooting
right now um but it's you know
filmmaking
is a pretty intimate process you get
pretty close to
the people around you and so you know it
does feel like there's a bit of a
a barrier yeah um between
you know what you're used to and and
like the
what we're doing now but at the same
time we're a couple months in now
and so we've kind of found our groove
with it we've kind of we found our new
normal which is cool because
you know at first you could tell
everybody was a little nervous
and you know didn't want to break the
rules and you know we had to we have
zoning on set and everything
and now that you know we've gotten
comfortable and we
know what our boundaries are
we're learning how to operate in that
and still have a good time yeah and i
probably can't say much but i'm gonna
try
where does season two pick up is there a
time
jump of any sort or is it pretty
immediate after
you know the bahamas and all that
um
i don't know what i'm allowed to say i
don't i really don't know
um but um
there is a
micro time jump okay that's that's fair
it's perfectly bang that's perfectly
vague
yeah i'll take it i don't want to pull a
tom holland
i got in trouble um recently for posting
something that i wasn't supposed to
so like now i'm paranoid i won't press
you too hard but
has anything shocked you about where
this story goes in season two
the kind of shock where you turn the
page
and you're reading and you read that
moment
and you're like wow and then
you know your mind starts going a
thousand miles a minute because you're
like oh my god this is gonna be so fun
to shoot oh my god like
holy like this is gonna be fun and it's
gonna be
shocking to watch as well um like there
have been a few moments
those a few of those moments that we've
shot already
and just having shot them and knowing
how they look on the day and knowing you
know how amazing
our post-production team is like it's
gonna look awesome how do
the pogs react when they find out that
sarah and john
are alive or does that even get answered
relatively quickly
it does get answered it's all good
things okay
are john b and sarah in a good place
they
i don't want to give away too much um
just because i i want
i want people to watch this yeah um with
like without knowing too much i want
people to watch this with
uh going into it kind of blind
yeah how how would you describe the
second season
much higher stakes the stakes are higher
okay um and uh the
the mystery gets deeper i know there's
some new cast members
elizabeth phil being one of them that
was announced what
reveal about her character she's a
villain seemingly
you know what i really love is that she
is a villain
but she
comes across in a way that you
completely empathize with her
it's almost like a um award situation
and i mean i'm not saying you can fully
empathize with ward he's
not a good guy but um you know
he has reasons for doing things
and i think that makes i think sometimes
i think
you have to have that approaching an
antagonist
is empathy for sure she's wonderful to
work with
and she's also she's killing it
truly so i'm excited for people to um
to see her on the show i talked to you
before the show
came out and i remember i feel like your
instagram had like 2 000 followers and
now you're like over 5 million
for you i mean how has life really
changed over the course of these past
few months and like what's that felt
like
it feels like an identity crisis
um it feels confusing it really does
because
i'm you know it's
i don't know it's definitely it's it's
new territory for sure
and it's also one of those things where
i feel like i meet people
and you know they've watched the show
and and i'm i feel bad because i'm like
i feel like
you're really underwhelmed right now
like it's interesting
um but it's a good time it's fun i feel
like
we've got a lot of friends everywhere um
and everybody's been really really nice
and pretty
this summer that respectful the past
back to life
what's that well let's talk about this
movie it's called the giant
yes i thought it was creepy
dark gritty psychological
what kind of drew you to the project as
you were reading
the script um it was exactly that it was
creepy
and it was psychological it was a
real mind twister i
did it was a real page turner because i
just didn't know what was gonna be next
and um i love films like that i love
films that really
leave you thinking for a couple days
afterwards like you just can't get it
out of your head
the script was very uh visceral in that
like there was lots of descriptives
about
the kudzu and the cicadas and
and that all felt like home so it was
like this weird
paradox of like creepy and you know the
fear of the unknown but also
home emotionally what kind of places do
you have to go to
um to shoot something like this when
it's an emotionally taxing scene
that's those are the days that are
sometimes a little bit harder to shape
than others
it's also very rewarding it's just like
emotional vomit and it's extremely
cathartic
and um you know you have to take a
moment after that
scene and you know like go find a spot
or a corner to
just kind of make sure you're good and
like check in with yourself
and then and then it's a bit of and then
it's like kind of an adrenaline rush
because you're sitting there like
when when it feels like you were
truthful
in that moment i don't think that there
is
a greater feeling than feeling like you
can walk away knowing you've done good
[Music]
work
you